.
*schnelle Musik*
Mit Vollgas vom Auto erfasst werden.
*Motorengeräusche*
6 Schüsse in den Körper bekommen.
*Schüsse*
Und 2 in den Kopf?
Oder bei lebendigem Leibe
verbrannt werden?
In den "Halloween"-Filmen
muss Serienkiller Michael Myers
ordentlich einstecken.
Ob sein Körper
das aushalten könnte,
das klären wir heute
gemeinsam mit einem echten Notarzt.
Am Ende der Folge werden wir
wissenschaftlich berechnen,
wie hoch
Michaels Überlebenschancen sind.
*schnelle Musik*
Guten Tag zusammen.
Mit "Halloween Ends"
läuft gerade der 13. Teil
der Horror-Reihe in den Kinos.
Wie es der Name schon sagt:
Dieser Film soll das große Finale
der Erzählung werden.
Come get me, mother fucker.
*schockender Sound*
Ob das wirklich
das Ende von Michael Myers ist,
das will ich nicht vorweg nehmen
oder in Stein meißeln.
Wenn wir auf die über 40-jährige
Geschichte der Reihe schauen,
ist klar:
Der Typ steht immer wieder auf.
*spannende Musik*
Beim Schauen der Filme
habe ich oft gedacht,
der müsste doch tot sein,
bei allem, was er abkriegt.
Ist das wirklich so?
Überlebt er das nur,
weil er übernatürlich ist?
Oder kann er
das wirklich überleben?
Das klären wir mit jemandem,
der Menschen beim Aufstehen hilft.
Mit Notfallmediziner
Philipp Gotthardt.
*spannende Musik*
Philipp arbeitet in der Notaufnahme
vom Klinikum Nürnberg-Süd.
Er ist regelmäßig als Notarzt
auf der Straße unterwegs.
Gemeinsam mit seinem Kumpel
und ehem. Kollegen Martin
betreibt er seit 2017
den YouTube-Kanal und Medizin-Blog
"Nerdfallmedizin".
Popcorn
gibt es bei ihm zu Comedy-Streifen.
Filme mit Will Ferrell
sind seine Favoriten.
Philipp, schön, dass du da bist.
- Servus.
Ich schaue gerne Horror-Filme.
Was mir immer auffällt,
auch bei "Halloween",
ich finde das Blut
sieht unrealistisch aus.
Wie geht es dir?
Du hast ja den direkten Vergleich.
Bei Verkehrsunfällen
bluten die Leute nicht so massiv.
Die bluten mehr nach innen.
Äußerlich
sehen sie oft unversehrt aus,
obwohl sie schwer verletzt sind.
Was immer total krass aussieht,
sind Kopfverletzungen.
Auch bei älteren Leuten,
die Blutverdünner nehmen.
Da ist alles voller Blut,
das ist Horrorfilm-Style.
Wenn es auf das Rentenalter zu geht,
muss man aufpassen.
Dann lass und mal schauen,
was die Überlebenskünste
von Michael Myers angeht.
Dafür bekommen wir Unterstützung:
Kati Winter hat einen YouTube-Kanal
für Horror-Stories.
Sie kennt sich gut aus mit dem Genre.
Sie stellt 3 prominente Arten vor,
wie versucht wurde,
Michael Myers loszuwerden.
Hier Nr.1:
*spannende Musik*
Hi, Jack.
Hi, Philipp.
Bei den "Halloween"-Filmen
ist mir aufgefallen,
weil es unüblich ist
für Horror-Killer:
Michael Myers
wird oft im Auto gezeigt.
Im 1. Teil
sehen wir ihn in 7 Szenen.
Er scheint es zu genießen
hinter dem Steuer zu sitzen.
Auf dem Weg zum nächsten Mord.
Hey Jerk!
Sweet kills!
Auf der anderen Seite
sind Autos ein beliebtes Mittel,
um ihn sprichwörtlich
aus dem Weg zu räumen.
In "Halloween 4"
wird er von einem Auto gerammt.
Und fliegt meterweit durch die Luft.
Um kurz danach wieder aufzustehen.
*dramatische Musik*
Dieselbe Taktik
fährt Officer Hawkins
im Film von 2018.
Dort nimmt er den Killer
mehrere Meter mit.
Der liegt dann
bewusstlos auf dem Boden.
Nur um kurz danach
auf der Rückbank wieder aufzuwachen.
Fuck!
*dramatische Musik*
*Schreie*
Danke, Kati.
Ich nehme an,
du musstest noch keinen verunglückten
Serienmörder behandeln.
Wenn wir auf die Szenen schauen:
Womit muss Michael rechnen,
was ist gefährlich?
Es hängt davon ab,
wo er auf das Auto schlägt.
Es gibt weiche und sehr harte Teile.
Die A-Säule
und der Rahmen der Windschutzscheibe
sind extrem hart.
Wenn man dort
mit dem Kopf gegenprallt,
ist das sehr gefährlich.
Wir schauen noch mal in die Szene.
Es sieht aus,
als ob er mittig aufprallt.
In beiden Fällen
haben die Autos
eine Metallschiene vorne dran.
Die treffen Michael
genau auf der Höhe des Beckens.
Wenn am Becken oder Oberschenkel
etwas bricht,
kann das zu massiven
inneren Verletzungen führen.
Im 1. Film
ist das es Ford aus den 70er Jahren.
Man sieht, wie Michael
beim Aufprall weggeschleudert wird.
Im 2. Beispiel
klappt er schon so nach vorne über.
Da landet er auf der Haube selbst.
*quietschende Reifen*
Das ist eigentlich
ein großer Vorteil für Michael.
Durch die lange Motorhaube
kommt er nicht in Kontakt
mit den harten Teilen.
Und die Motorhaube
ist bei neueren Autos relativ weich.
Die gibt etwas nach.
Das ist bei den alten Autos
aus der 1. Szene anders.
Da war das Blech härter,
man konnte die Haube mehr belasten.
Aber für die Fußgänger
war es gefährlicher.
Die Haube kann
die Wucht des Aufpralls abfedern.
Und mit viel Glück
hat er keine inneren Verletzungen.
Ja, mit viel Glück.
Dann muss zumindest der 1. Aufprall
nicht zwingend tödlich sein.
Aber du hast schon gesagt,
er wird auch
durch die Luft geschleudert.
Er fliegt rum
und landet auf dem Boden.
Das ist eine andere Nummer.
Ja, genau.
Du meinst
den Sekundäraufprall.
Denn tatsächlich, wenn Leute
optimal vom Auto getroffen werden.
Also auf die weichen Stellen
aufkommen.
Die Geschwindigkeit
nicht hoch ist.
Dann werden wir
von den Autos weggeschleudert
und knallen mit dem Kopf
massiv auf den harten Asphalt auf.
Das ist noch mal
richtig gefährlich.
Also in der 1. Szene
kommt er auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen besser weg.
Denn da knallt er zwar
mit dem Rücken durch den Holzzaun.
Das sieht echt ziemlich
gefährlich aus im 1. Moment.
Aber ich finde,
die Bretter wirken ziemlich morsch.
Außerdem fängt er sich
ja auch mit den Armen ab.
Und es liegt
ganz viel Laub auf dem Boden.
Das wirkt fast wie eine Turnmatte.
Die federt da sicherlich
gut den Sturz ab.
In der 2. Szene
knallt er volle Kanne
mit dem Hinterkopf auf.
Wenn er da wirklich
aus voller Fahrt aufgeschlagen ist,
dann sieht es
wirklich schlecht für ihn aus.
Womit würdet du rechnen?
Die meisten Menschen
sterben nach einem Verkehrsunfall
an einem Schädel-Hirn-Trauma.
Das heißt
durch die massive Gewalteinwirkung,
die auf das Gehirn einwirkt.
Man sieht ja auch
in der letzten Szene,
dass er minutenlang
bewusstlos am Boden liegt.
Das ist ein klares Indiz
für ein Schädel-Hirn-Trauma.
Philipp, dann würde ich sagen,
dein finales Fazit.
Kann Michael das überleben?
- Na ja.
Ich würde
bei so einem Unfall-Mechanismus
auf jeden Fall davon ausgehen,
dass schwere
innere Verletzungen vorliegen.
Wirbelsäulentrauma, Beckentrauma.
Aber Michael
ist auch ein resilienter Typ.
Der hat ja nicht
alle Schrauben fest im Griff.
Von daher würde ich sagen,
mit ganz viel Glück
kann er das schon überleben.
Dann müssen wir festhalten,
Autos sind nicht zuverlässig genug.
Vielleicht braucht man
was mit mehr Speed.
Pistolenkugeln!
*Musik*
"Lieber auf Nummer sicher gehen!"
Das ist die Devise,
wenn es um Michael Myers geht.
Deshalb ist es auch Dr. Loomis,
sein Psychiater,
der im 1. Teil auf Michael
aus nächster Nähe schießt.
Aber nicht nur einmal.
Er setzt gleich 5 Schüsse nach.
*Schüsse*
Juckt Michael aber nicht.
Denn der taucht im 2. Teil
wieder auf.
Um seine Lieblingsopfer-Frau
Laurie Strode zu töten.
Die hat anscheinend
aus der Erfahrung
aus dem 1. Teil gelernt.
Sie zielt statt auf seinen Körper
auf seinen Kopf.
Sie trifft in beide Augen.
*Schuss*
Okay, Philipp,
das sind 2 krasse Szenen,
die wir da gesehen haben.
Lass mal mit der 1. starten.
Ich habe schon mal
von jemandem gehört,
der einen Schuss überlebt hat.
Aber 6-mal hintereinander?
Na ja, das gibt es schon.
Ich denke da
an den Amerikaner Kenny Worn.
Der wurde bei einem
Nachbarschaftsstreit
20-mal angeschossen.
Teilweise sogar
aus 1,5 m Entfernung.
Nur der letzte Schuss,
der ging in den Unterleib
und dann durch den Mastdarm.
Da war so eine Mischung aus Fäkalien
und Blut in seinem Unterleib.
Also hochinfektiös.
Trotzdem hat der Typ das überlebt.
Holy shit, wie ist das möglich?
Bei Schussverletzungen
sind im Endeffekt
2 Dinge ausschlaggebend.
Da ist die Verletzung
von inneren Organen und Gefäßen.
Die massiven Blutungen.
Auf der anderen Seite,
wenn das Gehirn verletzt wird.
Wenn man
richtige Hirnareale trifft.
Dann tötet ein Kopfschuss sofort.
Wobei innere Blutungen
töten erst etwas verspätet.
Innerhalb von Minuten oder Stunden.
Bei Kenny Worn war das so.
Da gab es 2 Faktoren, die ihm
beim Überleben geholfen haben.
Die kann man auch
auf Michael anwenden.
Zum einen die Projektil-Größe.
Die bestimmt, wie viel Energie
auf den Körper abgegeben wird,
da sich die Kugel auf dem Weg
durch den Körper verformt.
Bei Worn waren das Gewehrschüsse.
Da ist ein kleines Projektil
mit sehr hoher Geschwindigkeit
im Einsatz.
Wenn das einen aus der Nähe trifft,
dann geht das Projektil
direkt durch den Körper.
Es gibt also
wenig Energie auf den Körper ab.
Michael hat da ein bisschen Pech,
denn die Pistole von Dr. Loomis
ist eine Smith und Wesson 15.
Das ist eine Polizeipistole
aus den 50ern bis 80ern.
Bei dem Kaliber ist es eben so,
dass die Schüsse aus nächster Nähe
sehr, sehr viel Energie
auf den können Körper abgeben.
Der taumelt so richtig zurück.
Da ist ordentlich Bumms
hinter den Geschossen.
Aber der 2. ausschlaggebende Punkt
beim Überleben ist:
Man weiß nie genau, welchen Weg
die Kugel durch den Körper nimmt.
Nachdem sie eingedrungen ist.
Das ist ein Vorteil für Michael?
- Ja, genau.
Also Doktor Loomis schießt
ziemlich unkontrolliert auf Michael.
Wir sehen gar nicht genau,
wo er getroffen wird.
Bei Kenny Worn war es so ...
Der hatte einfach totales Glück.
Die Kugeln haben exakt
an lebenswichtigen Organen vorbei
den Weg durch den Körper gesucht.
Das ist natürlich
ein großer Vorteil.
Aber man muss auch sagen,
vielleicht hat Michael
auch Blähungen.
Blähungen, also Gase im Körper.
Ja, du lachst, aber es ist so.
Die dämpfen die Schuss-Energie
tatsächlich ab.
Wenn einer vorher Suppe
oder Wasser trinkt,
das kann man nicht komprimieren.
Dann wird die Geschossenergie
auf den Körper verteilt.
Das ist sehr gefährlich.
Okay, dann danke
für diesen Hausmanns-Trick!
Michael, also bitte:
Hülsenfrüchte ja.
Suppe lieber nicht.
Dann sind die Kugeln hier
ja offensichtlich so geflogen,
dass sie keine lebenswichtigen
Organe oder Gefäß verletzt haben.
Michael verblutet nicht.
Das passt zur Storyline.
Da wird Michael
nach den Schüssen gerettet
und von der Polizei gestellt.
*düstere Musik und Gemurmel*
Das ist auch ein wichtiger Punkt.
Weil nach einer Schussverletzung
ist eine extrem
hohe Infektionsgefahr da.
Man muss sofort
ärztlich versorgt werden.
Das klappt ja,
wenn die Polizei ihn aufgreift.
Krass, Philipp.
Dann können wir ja hier festhalten:
Szene 1:
Michael kann das überleben.
Aber Szene 2,
diese 2 Schüsse in den Kopf.
Das ist doch Quatsch, oder?
Also wenn man ehrlich ist:
Auch das kann man sogar
in der Theorie überleben.
What?
Also, man muss mal sagen,
wahrscheinlich wäre er blind.
Man verstirbt zwar
an den allermeisten Kopfschüssen.
Aber es kommt auch darauf an,
wo man genau getroffen wird
und welchen Weg die Kugel
durch den Schädel nimmt.
Da ist es so:
Projektile mit niedriger Energie
können oft nicht mehr
aus dem Schädel austreten.
Sie werden wie ein Ball
hin und her reflektiert.
Das gibt
einen massiven Gehirnschaden.
Es hängt davon ab,
wo und womit man getroffen wird.
Wo die Kugel das Gehirn trifft,
sehen wir nicht.
Das ist unter der Maske.
Aber wir sehen,
dass sie nicht wieder austritt.
Es ist kein Blut an der Maske.
Die Kugel bleibt im Kopf stecken.
Ja, da hast du vollkommen recht.
Aber die Kugel trifft Michael
von unten nach oben.
Wenn er Glück hat,
wandert die Kugel
an der inneren Schädeldecke entlang
und kommt in der hinteren
Schädelgrube zum Liegen.
Sie trifft nicht auf den Hirnstamm,
da liegen
die lebenswichtigen Funktionen.
Wird man da getroffen,
ist man sofort tot.
Außen ist die Hirnrinde.
Da kann man Verletzungen überleben.
Es gibt einen Fallbericht
über einen 53-jährigen Mann,
der ähnlich wie Michael
getroffen wurde.
Die Kugeln sind hinten
in der Hirnfurche stecken geblieben.
Der Mann
hat sich vollständig erholt.
Aber er war anfangs bewusstlos
und musste notoperiert werden.
Bei Michael
ist das etwas unrealistisch.
Er taumelt nur.
Normalerweise
haut einen die Wucht von den Socken.
Wir können noch mal
über die Projektil-Größe sprechen.
Das sieht dort so ähnlich aus
wie der Revolver aus der 1. Szene.
Da ist viel Bumms dahinter.
- Das Projektil hat da viel Energie.
Das würde einem
den halben Schädel wegsprengen.
Aber auch da gibt es ein Beispiel.
Ein Teenager wurde
von einer heruntergefallenen Waffe
direkt in den Kopf getroffen.
Das zerstörte ihm große Teile
des Schädels und des Großhirns.
Den halben Schädel
hat es weggesprengt.
Man sah das damals
als medizinisches Wunder.
Nach der OP konnte er sofort
mit den Ärzten sprechen.
Bis zuletzt konnte er
ein recht normales Leben führen.
Wow.
Wenn Michael nach den Schüssen
schnell versorgt wird,
hat das keine Folgen für ihn?
Gar keine Folgen sicher nicht.
Ihm wird direkt
ins Frontalhirn geschossen.
Dort werden Emotionen
und Persönlichkeit gemacht.
Entweder wird man dann etwas lieber
oder aber viel, viel fieser.
Okay.
Was wir nicht gebrauchen können,
ist einen noch fieseren Michael.
Das wäre das Gegenteil von dem,
was Laurie Strode erreichen wollte.
Wir können festhalten:
6 Schüsse in den Körper zu bekommen,
2 in den Kopf
und dann weiterzumachen,
ist medizinisch unwahrscheinlich.
Aber mit schneller Versorgung
nicht ganz ausgeschlossen.
Der Typ ist nicht totzukriegen.
Aber einen Versuch haben wir noch.
*dramatische Musik*
Wenn Autos,
Schüsse und andere Attacken
bei Michael Myers
nicht mehr funktionieren,
setzt man auf die Kraft
einer fetten Explosion.
Die wird kurz nach dem Kopfschuss
im 2. Teil von Dr. Loomis ausgelöst.
It's time, Michael.
*Knall*
Lichterloh brennend sieht man
Michael den Gang entlangwanken.
Dann fällt er zu Boden.
Im letzten Shot
sieht man seine brennende Maske.
Im Film von 2018 dreht die gealterte
Laurie Strode den Gashahn auf.
Michael hatte sie
in ihr Haus gesperrt.
Goodbye, Michael.
Den scheint das nicht zu stören.
Er kann sich verstecken
und ist dort sicher,
bis die Feuerwehr auftaucht.
Für seine Retter hat er
noch eine zündende Idee,
um sie gebührend zu begrüßen.
Hier wieder 2 Szenen.
Lass uns mit der beginnen,
wo sich Michael
vor den Flammen versteckt.
Um ihn herum
brennt das ganze Haus lichterloh ab.
Kann man sich hinter einem Rolltor
vor den Flammen schützen?
Wir gehen davon aus, dass er sich
direkt hinter dem Tor versteckt.
Das Haus steht in Vollbrand.
Im Haus sind Temperaturen
von über 1.000°C.
Ob das Rolltor ausreicht,
um ihn zu schützen ...
Ich weiß nicht.
Wir müssen uns hier
auf die Autor*innen verlassen.
Die sagen,
das sei ein feuerfestes Tor.
Aber trotzdem.
Es gibt heiße Gase,
die man einatmet.
Stichwort Inhalations-Trauma.
Ich atme das heiße Zeug ein,
das reizt meine Schleimhäute.
Die schwellen an,
daran kann man ersticken.
Eine knifflige Kiste.
Obendrein sind die Gase giftig.
- Genau.
Kohlenmonoxid würde sich ausbreiten.
Die Vergiftung daran
gehört zu den häufigsten
tödlichen Vergiftungen mit Gasen.
Kohlenmonoxid blockiert
die Sauerstoff-Aufnahme
der roten Blutkörperchen.
Daran erstickt man schnell
oder wird ohnmächtig.
Kohlenmonoxid greift auch
das zentrale Nervensystem an.
Man wird orientierungslos,
bekommt dann Krampfanfälle.
Irgendwann fällt man ins Koma.
Michael
müsste hier Atemschutz tragen.
Das sehen wir natürlich nicht.
Es findet
hinter den Rolltoren statt.
Wenn wir sagen,
Michael hat minimal vorgesorgt.
Wie hoch sind seine Chancen,
das zu überleben?
Das kann man recht genau abschätzen.
Und zwar mit dem Absi-Score.
Den gibt es seit den 80ern.
Es fließen Parameter ein,
die Punkte ergeben.
Die addiert man am Ende.
So kann man das Überleben nach einer
Brandverletzung einschätzen.
Okay, cool.
Dann rechnen wir das
für euch mal aus.
Michael ist männlich,
das gibt 0 Punkte.
Frauen würden einen Punkt bekommen.
Wobei das mittlerweile
aber ziemlich überholt ist.
Als nächstes
vergibt man Punkte für das Alter.
Pro 20 Lebensjahre einen Punkt.
Wie alt ist Michael hier?
Im Film von 2018 ist er 61.
Also 3 Punkte.
Dann wird die verbrannte
Körperoberfläche mit einbezogen.
Das sind 0% hier.
Also 2-mal 0 Punkte.
Und er kriegt einen Punkt
für das Inhalations-Trauma.
Sind 4 Punkte.
Das wäre nach Absi-Score
90-99% Überlebenschance.
Mega gut!
Der Film hat uns nicht angelogen.
Michael kommt unter guten Umständen
raus aus der Nummer.
Das Gleiche können wir
für die 2. Szene machen.
Aus "Halloween 2".
Da wird es sicher anders laufen.
Denn da ist es richtig extrem.
Michael steht ja da
als menschliche Fackel.
Ja, aber v.a.
wird er einer Explosion ausgesetzt.
Die macht ein extremes Trauma,
eine Druckwelle.
Das sorgt für innere Verletzungen,
für Schädel-Hirn-Trauma.
Das schleudert einen durch die Luft.
Harte Nummer.
Du meinst,
da muss er viel Glück gehabt haben,
dass er überhaupt
aus der Explosion rauskommt.
Er hat so viel Glück,
dass er nur ein bisschen
über den Gang taumelt.
Da habe ich mich gefragt:
Wenn man so brennt,
kann man dann einfach so rumlaufen?
Merkt man das noch?
Ist man da fähig?
Es geht tatsächlich.
Wenn man massive Verbrennungen hat,
spürt man das teilweise nicht mehr.
D.h., so Schwerstverbrannte
sind am Anfang ...
Das wirkt auch ziemlich gruselig.
Trotz ihrer massiven Verletzungen,
die später auch zum Tod führen,
wirken sie am Anfang erst mal
noch recht lebendig.
Aber natürlich sind sie trotzdem
massiv von ihrem Trauma betroffen.
Sie wälzen sich auf dem Boden,
sind unter Schock.
Und Michael, der Psychopath,
taumelt nur ein bisschen.
Okay, der ist wieder mal
völlig unnormal.
Lass uns mal
über die Flammen an sich sprechen.
Wie schwer müssten hier
seine Verletzungen sein?
Verbrennungen teilt man ein
in Schweregrade.
Vom 1. bis 3. Grad.
Je länger jemand brennt
oder Feuer ausgesetzt ist,
desto tiefer geht die Verbrennung
in die Haut hinein.
Michael hat sicherlich
Verbrennungen 3. Grades.
D.h. eine komplette Zerstörung
aller Hautschichten.
Da spürt man auch nichts mehr,
denn auch die Nerven sind zerstört.
Diese Verletzungen gehen einher
mit massiver Narbenbildung.
Und müssen immer
operativ versorgt werden.
Also Haut-Transplantation?
Genau.
Man muss erst
das tote Gewebe wegschneiden.
Dann muss man die großen Wund-Areale
wieder abdecken.
Dafür kann man z.T.
sogar Leichenhaut verwenden.
Leichenhaut?
Genau.
Man würde immer erst versuchen,
eigene Haut der Patienten zu nehmen.
Aber bei Michael
ist fast alles verbrannt.
Da bleibt nur
ein Fremd-Präparat übrig.
Wow, okay.
Das zeigt auch noch mal
die Schwere dieser Verletzungen.
Er hat am ganzen Körper
diese Verbrennungen.
Und bestimmt
ein hohes Infektionsrisiko?
Ja, das Infektionsrisiko
ist riesengroß.
Auch die Flüssigkeits-Verluste.
Das zu überleben,
ist eine harte Nummer.
Haben wir
Michaels Achillesferse gefunden?
Kriegen wir den mit Feuer tot?
Definitiv.
Berechnen wir noch mal
den Absi-Score.
In diesem Film ist er viel jünger.
Aber seine Körperoberfläche
ist fast zu 100% verbrannt.
Und 3. Grades
plus Inhalations-Trauma.
Da komme ich auf 13 Punkte.
Also weniger als 10%
Überlebens-Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Und man muss sich
die Maske anschauen.
Die brennt ja.
Die ist aus Plastik.
Die schmelzt sich
komplett am Gesicht fest.
Da geht nichts mehr.
Dann haben wir
das Mittel unserer Wahl gefunden.
Wenn wir Michael Myers
loswerden wollen,
müssen wir ihn einfach nur
bei 1.000°C von allen Seiten
für ein paar Minuten gut durchrösten.
Philipp, danke für deine Erklärungen.
- Gerne.
Ihr habt noch mehr Lust
auf medizinische Themen?
Dann schaut mal bei Philipp vorbei.
"Nerdfallmedizin" heißt das Ganze.
Links packen wir in die Infobox.
Ein Dank auch an Dr. Frank Siemers
vom Brandverletzten-Zentrum Halle.
Er hat uns
bei der Recherche geholfen.
Genauso wie der ADAC.
Vielen Dank!
Und großen Dank an Kati
für ihre Einspieler.
Wenn ihr jetzt Bock auf Fiction habt,
dann flitzt rüber zu ihrem Kanal.
Dort gibt es jede Menge
gute Horror-Stories.
Wir wünschen euch ...
- Fröhliche Halloween!
Aber nur, wenn ihr ...
Den Kanal abonniert
und auf die Glocke drückt.
Sonst gibt es keine Süßigkeiten.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich würde mich freuen.
Tschau.
Michael, kennst du schon
unsere anderen Horrorfolgen?
Dann guck dir die mal an.
Hier oben gibt es Zombies
bei "Resident Evil".
Und hier gibt es Vampire
mit "Morbius".
Copyright MDR 2022